lui-même t a les deux pieds au bord du
précipice climatique mais refuse de le
reconnaître
conclut le rapport du giec un groupe
d'experts internationaux mandatés par
l'onu pour faire le point sur les
changements climatiques
près de 200 états ont entériné le
rapport de 3000 pages présenté par le
giec pour ceux qui en doutaient encore
il confirme que lui mais le principal
responsable de la hausse de la
température mondiale provoquée par les
gaz à effet de serre et des conséquences
catastrophiques et qu'elle entraîne les
changements du climat sont en train de
transformer le climat de l'ensemble des
régions de la planète
c'est de plus en plus rapide ça va
s'intensifier l'hydrosphère les océans
en ce moment on observe une hausse
moyenne de la température sur terre de
1,1 degré celsius par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle où est mme actuels
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
atteindra le seuil de la corde paris 1,5
degrés autour de 2030 soit disant plutôt
prévu en l'absence de gestes concrets
disent les experts ou pourrait même
dépasser les 2 3 voire 4 degrés celsius
d'ici la fin du siècle avait précipité
shawn andrews lors du sommet sur le
climat qui se tiendra en novembre
prochain à glasgow en ecosse les pays
participants essaieront donc de
s'entendre sur les prochaines cibles à
atteindre
mais si les changements d'habitudes de
vie devront être radicaux et avoir lieu
dans un avenir très rapproché explique
le rapport qui est encore possible de
limiter les dégâts heureusement il ya
quand même des sillons possible c'est à
dire que le rapport présente toute une
série de scénarios que l'on peut réussir
à atteindre de façon à réussir
trollé l'ampleur du changement
climatique la dernière fois que les
niveaux de gaz à effet de serre étaient
aussi levé sur terre souligne le
document c'était il ya trois millions
d'années ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal